j moins vite avant le second tour des
élections municipales et la grande
question cette période de crise
sanitaire c'est l'abstention selon une
enquête de l'institut de sondages ifop
plus de 6 électeurs sur dix pourrait ne
pas se rendre aux urnes le 28 juin par
crainte du virus
autre argument pour ne pas aller voter
évoquée par les sondés le délai
particulièrement longs entre le premier
et le second tour
fabien roussel secrétaire national pcf
est député de la 20e circonscription du
nord nous dévoile le programme du parti
communiste avec pour leitmotiv la
solidarité écouter ce que nous mettons
en avant
ce sont des villes citoyenne solidaire
écologistes ce sont des villes qui par
exemple mettre en place des centres
municipaux de santé
faisons en sorte que tous les soins
citoyens d'une ville est accès à une
médecine de proximité de proximité ce
sont des villes où nous nous battons
pour l'accès à des transports les moins
chers possibles voire gratuit à chaque
fois que c'est possible
nous voulons apporter notre contribution
contre la pollution pour le climat avec
des transports gratuits partout ce sont
des villes aussi où nous faisons en
sorte de lutter contre la spéculation
immobilière en permettant à chaque
citoyen d'avoir accès à un toit de
donner droit au logement
ce sont des principes que nous voulons
mettre en oeuvre partout où c'est
possible
c'est donc des villes citoyenne
solidaire écologistes chaque ville
chaque citoyen peut participer à ce
combat